[MUSIC]
Well it is my pleasure today
to introduce to you Dr.
Stephen Shueller, who I told him
I was gonna introduce him as
a friend of the family
because he is.
Actually way back when we
started with PopTherapy,
he was really influential in
helping Pablo Paredes design his
interventions.
I remember Pablo being on
the phone with you for
hours talking about how to
design real psychological
interventions that people
would actually use.
So he's here, but
he's here from the University of
Northwestern, Northwestern
University, from the Department
of Preventative Medicine and
the Center for Behavioral and
Intervention Technologies,
or they call it CBIT.
He's also a director of a,
remind me the name of it again?
>> PsyberGuide.
>> PsyberGuide, right.
Which is a super useful tool.
The thing that's interesting
about Stephen is he really works
on making mental health and
wellbeing interventions
accessible and
universally available to all,
which we love here.
So I'm sure he'll tell
you all about that today,
thank you for coming.
>> Awesome, thank you so much.
So as Mary said,
my name is Stephen Schueller.
I'm in the Department of
Preventive Medicine at
Northwestern University, but
I'm trained as
a clinical psychologist.
And a lot of the work that
I do right now lays at
the intersection of
sort of three fields.
Clinical psychology, a design in
human-computer interaction, and
implementation science.
And so one of the questions
that really drives me now is,
there's been a lot of evidence
that shows that technology-based
mental health can be useful.
But it really hasn't caught on,
despite this rampant
enthusiasm for developing
these sorts of things.
And so, really I think that we
as a field need to consider
how can we make sure that the
stuff that we develop actually
gets used in places where it
can be helpful for people?
So I'm gonna go through some
examples of some of the work
that I'm doing that kind of
spans different ways of thinking
about how to get technologies
out there, how to evaluate
technologies, how to build
technologies for diverse groups.
And conclude with some
thoughts about the future
of sort of mobile mental health.
So again,
I'm a clinical psychologist.
I imagine, and I know most of
the people here at Microsoft
are not clinical psychologists.
And so, I wanna talk a little
bit about the scope of
the problem, but then also how I
think more about sort of mental
health as it applies
more broadly.
So I work mostly in
the area of depression.
Depression is a very
widespread problem.
So depression is actually
the largest contributor to
disability, approximately one in
five folks in the United States
will experience a mental
health disorder.
So by that I mean a clinically
diagnosable version of a mental
health condition.
So depression anxiety
are the most common,
but also more serious mental
illness like schizophrenia and
bipolar disorder.
These things are just
extremely prevalent.
One in five means it's not like
someone you know somewhere
in your social network
has a mental disorder.
This means that the people that
you interact with on a daily
basis, the people who are
intimately involved in your life
experience mental health issues.
The other thing I wanna kind of
point out in this figure over
here is that mental health is
not just about presence or
absence of disorders, but it's
also a continuum of functioning.
So I think this is sort of a
good representation that usually
when we think about sort
of mental health disorders,
we think about disorders
versus everything else.
But everyone experiences times
in their life where they
experience some degree of
mental health challenge.
This kind of yellow
box here is reacting.
So reacting means something's
going on in your life.
I have two year old triplets.
I can tell you that when
those kids were born,
it was a very stressful time.
My mental health was not
the best state at that time.
That didn't mean I had a mental
health disorder, that meant I
was experiencing a time in
my life that was stressful.
Wasn't sleeping as well, wasn't
eating as well, wasn't being as
active, all these things that
kinda promote mental health.
And so that's also something
that we need to address as
mental health professionals and
as folks who are interested
in promoting mental health.
To acknowledge that the
stressors that come up in our
lives and how we react to those
are also things that we can
develop tools and
resources to help people with.
So it's not just am I healthy,
or do I have a mental disorder,
but all these sort of
steps along that line.
So I have this quote here from
the former US Surgeon General,
there's no health
without mental health.
And what I often say is, it's
not just one in five Americans
have a mental health disorder.
100% of Americans have to
deal with mental health.
This is something that we
should be thinking about.
This, on the other hand, is
a very depressing figure for me.
So what this figure shows
is the representation of
licensed psychologists.
This is only psychologists but
if I showed you any other sort
of figure that was a
representation of mental health
professionals, it would
look about the same.
So there's about 196,000
licensed clinical
psychologists in the US.
33% of US counties have not one
single Licensed mental health
professional.
So in the red, you'll see places
where there's a very high
concentration of mental
health professionals.
So if you live on coast,
either coast.
If you lived in kind
of Chicago area,
you can probably find
a clinical psychologist.
If you lived anywhere else,
you're gonna be in trouble.
And if you live in sort of this
big stretch of the country here,
that's where we have a real sort
of dearth of unprofessionals.
So there's lots of places
where you don't have
the choice to even
get professional
mental health services
if you want them.
And so this is a big problem
that I think technology has
a potential to kind of overcome.
So of course there's an app for
everything, we know this and
there's been rapid development
of mental health apps.
So this is kind of based off
a report from the IMS institute
that came out in 2015.
I mean, I know that that's
a little outdated now.
I'll say that when they did
the same report In 2013,
they estimated there were about
100,000 mental health apps.
So from 2013 to 2015,
it jumped by nearly
a little bit more than 50%.
So they estimated in 2015 that
there were roughly 165,000
health apps that are out there.
There's a more recent report
from a different institute I saw
that estimated about 250,000,
which would be keeping up with
about the rate of development
that we've seen there.
About roughly 12,000
of those are focused
towards mental health.
That's a ton of stuff
that's out there.
We don't know how good
all these things are.
We don't know how
helpful they are.
But there's a lot of different
things out there that
are purported to be
able to help people for
different mental
health disorders.
Here's just a little bit
of review of looking at
the scientific evidence
behind those things.
These come from two separate
systematic reviews.
Where what the office did in
both of these papers is they
looked at all the apps that were
publicly available on the app
stores focused on
a particular problem.
So the top one focuses
on depression,
this lower one
focuses on anxiety.
The findings are relatively
similar in that, for
depression they found 117 apps.
For anxiety they found 316,
about 10% of
those were consistent with
evidence based practices.
And by that I mean, they went to
the content of the applications.
They looked what was in there.
And they saw,
does this coincide with what
someone would recommend people
to do from sort of evidence
based psychological practices.
So about 10% of the time,
those abstracts are consistent.
They're actually, in several
reviews we find that there's
a lot of apps that even
have maybe harmful content.
There's one that's cited
pretty regularly for
bipolar disorder where it tells
you if your moods are kind of
getting more disruptive.
This mood swings are very common
bipolar, you might try to
help it by drinking more cuz
that will depress your moods.
And it's,
this information is out there.
And it's, if it's these apps
are sort of useless at best
sometimes, and
harmful at the worst.
And so, we really need
a lot more resources and
efforts to try to be able to
provide useful information to
consumers about what mental
health apps are out there.
Which ones might be useful,
which ones might be good.
That sort of typical way we
think about evaluating things in
medicine and clinical psychology
is through sort of a gold
standard randomized
control trial.
Where we have random assignment
to two different programs,
you do a pre-test, you do
the program, you do a post test.
This is really great.
But unfortunately,
to do sort of the size of trials
that we typically think about
in clinical psychology as what
we would want in this gold
standard measurements.
This is a extremely
slow process and
so I'm not saying
that we shouldn't
evaluate some things through
randomized control trials.
But I also think that in
the context of digital mental
health, we have to think about
other evaluation strategies.
That can supplement
the information we gained
from randomized control trials.
So, as Mary mentioned,
I am the executive director of
a project called PsyberGuide.
The goal at PsyberGuide is
to identify, curate, and
disseminate information
about mental health apps.
We're funded by
the One Mind Institute,
which is a non-profit that
promotes mental health research.
And we try to provide unbiased
information, kind of like
the consumer reports of
digital mental health.
So what does the PsyberGuide
website look like?
What sort of things do
we provide for folks?
We just try to organize
different mental health apps
around different
disorder categories.
Ranging from mood disorders,
things like depression,
schizophrenia, serious
mental illness, PTSD and
other anxiety disorders.
And as well as sort of, general
wellness tools made to promote
mental health sort
of more Generally.
We divide things up also by the
type of strategy that they have.
I'll say that most of the tools
in the area of depression and
anxiety tend to be cognitive
behavioral therapy based.
This is the strongest.
Well, I should say, this is
the treatment with the strongest
evidence based in
clinical psychology.
Does not necessarily mean that
it's the strongest treatment.
It means that it's the most
manualized treatment, so
that I mean that we as clinical
psychologists kind of lay down.
If you wanna do cognitive
behavioral therapy,
this is how you do it.
This is what your
sessions could cover.
These are the tools
that you need.
And so, it's been subjected to
the most of these randomized
controlled trials.
So I'm not saying,
it's the only thing that works.
But I'm saying that it's
the thing with the most evidence
that shows that it works.
We also have a lot
of symptom trackers.
These are very popular as
I'll talk about later.
A lot of mindfulness tools.
I'll say just as sort of
a point of what people
are interested in
mobile mental health.
On the PsyberGuide website
besides our main page and
our product guide which
obviously have the most views,
because that's where people
kind of go through the site.
The most popular
piece of content on our site is
the review we post of Headspace.
Headspace is an extremely
popular mental health app.
It has I think an estimated ten
million people who've used it.
The founder of
Headspace is TED Talk,
has 7 million views like people
really, really like Headspace.
Whether again, that means it's
the best mental health app out
there, I think that's debatable.
I've used Headspace.
It doesn't really capture me,
but
I'm also not really
a strong meditator.
But it's one that's extremely
popular with people.
So if you click on
our product guide,
you'll see a listing of
different mental health apps.
We list three different ratings
on our website right now.
One is the PsyberGuide rating,
which is a measure
of credibility.
Through the PsyberGuide rating,
we look at sort of
the evidence based.
Is there scientific evidence
that suggests that this mental
health app is useful?
Is it created by a scientific
team or does it have scientist,
or clinical advisor support
that would suggest that these
are people who know
how to create and
design effective
clinical interventions?
Is it updated frequently?
Does it have support behind?
The product, is it coming
from a non profit or
is it coming from a for
profit organization?
But next thing we look at
is using something called
the mobile app rating skill.
This is a measure that was
developed from folks out of
the University of Queensland
to evaluate help apps.
It focuses a lot on like the
usability and user experience.
So it could be that
there is a app that has
very good credibility,
but it's very hard to use.
I think we see this a lot.
Because often times in
scientific studies to get people
to use apps to to get people
to participate in the study,
there are incentivized
through financial incentives.
There might be a lot of sort of
education on how to use that app
in that randomized
control trial.
So that means if people are
really motivated to use this and
they get a lot of sort of
troubleshooting around it,
they'll use it and
they can benefit.
But if you put it out there and
you don't have that support,
people might have
a hard time using it.
So I think that, again, you kind
of need both of these things to
make a really
useful application.
I'm sure I'm preaching to the
choir here that effectiveness,
usefulness is not just does it
work, but can people use it.
But this is an important piece
that is usually left out in
a lot of the psychological
discussion from the clinical
psychology background
of these tools.
And then lastly,
we have expert reviews for
some of these apps which is we
have an expert in the field that
knows that content area.
That's cognitive
behavioral therapy app.
For depression, you might
have a depression expert.
It's a mindfulness app.
We might have a mindfulness
expert, but they create more
a narrative for users about
how you might use this app,
how it might be able
to benefit you.
So, just a little bit of
discussion around what we found
from mental health apps through
this endeavor of rating them.
From PsyberGuide rating, we rate
everything on a 14-point scale
and then present everything
as a percentage.
So apps can range from 0 to 100,
hypothetically.
Our actual range is 14 through
93% with an average of 52%.
So, there's some apps that look
really credible out there.
There's some apps
that look really bad.
It's PsyberGuide, we try to
not just rate the good apps.
Because we feel if someone finds
an app, we want them to know.
If they find brain each queue,
we want them to know like,
is this a good app?
Is this not a good app?
And so we really try to shy away
from the strategy of identifying
and recommending specific apps.
Our goal is really to put
the information out there in
a useful way for our consumers.
So you can see from the
percentiles that It does look
like a lot of the apps do pretty
well on this credibility rating.
Well, a lot of apps,
let's just say,
cluster around the center in
terms of credibility rating.
So, there's not a lot
at this high end,
there's not a lot
at this low end.
There's a lot of apps
that there's some,
it might be useful,
we don't really know.
For the MARS ratings,
60% of our products have
these MARS ratings.
Every product listed has
a PsyberGuide rating.
The range here again is 1.63 to
4.75 with an average of 3.5,
so things do okay on
this user rating scale.
Again, the interquartile range
shows that a lot of stuff
kind of clusters in
the middle there.
I'll say that these
credibility and
these MARS rating scales are
almost not correlated at all.
So the correlation between these
things are about an R of 0.2.
And I say not correlated at all
because practically anything you
correlate in psychology will get
an R of 0.2, it just happens.
Things are somewhat correlated.
They also don't correlate
very highly with our
ratings off of
the public app stores.
Neither the Mars rating nor
the PsyberGuide rating.
So it seems like if we just
look at the user ratings and
scores, but that's not
really representing either
the credibility or
the user experience of that.
So it's hard to say then from a
user's perspective when they go
and rate this applications
on app stores
what they're
actually looking at.
I'm also saying in terms of
public facing app store ratings,
so thanks off to
Google Play Store and
the Apple iTunes Store.
There's a lot of
these applications
that are very popular in either
the clinical literature or
the popular literature that
have no public sort of
rating on the app stores because
they don't have enough ratings.
That at least on the iTunes
Store, you need a certain number
of ratings before they
actually display the average.
And usually most of these mental
health apps don't have them.
I think about 10% of the apps
that we've looked at
actually have publicly available
ratings on the app stores.
In terms of the expert reviews,
about 30% of our products
have expert reviews.
And so
the expert reviews do look at
the higher range of the product.
So we have a average
Psyberguide rating of 60 and
an average MARS rating of 3.79.
So again, we try to focus on the
upper range of products there.
We don't really feel
like we need to provide
consumers with a lot of
information about how to use
the products that we don't
seem to be all that good.
We really wanna direct people
to things that we think
might be more useful.
So one of the things actually
we'd like to do more in
the future with PsyberGuide
is we wanna look more
also at integrating
the user experience of
their impression of
these applications.
As I've said,
the public consumer
marketplaces of app stores is
that those ratings don't really
relate to the information
that we're gathering.
And so we like to gain more
understanding of what it is that
people like and don't like
about applications and
how we can present
that back to them.
So that's one thing that we're
really kind of focusing on now
is how we engage the consumers
as stakeholders in terms
of contributing information
that we can then disseminate.
I think this is a really
big need for mental,
digital mental health more
generally is engaging
stakeholders more in the process
of both the development and
the evaluation piece of this.
Yeah.
>> Does the FDA regulate any
of these mental health apps?
>> The FDA does
not currently regulate any
of these mental health apps.
The FDA only regulates health
apps if they are used for
the purposes of assessment,
of providing an intervention.
So, if you were,
if you developed an app that
was meant to sort of diagnose
you for a mental disorder and
then provide that
information into clinician.
It would be arguable
that that would be,
should be regulated by the FDA.
These apps are really sold
as sort of do it yourself or
self management tools and so
they don't fall under
the FDA regulation.
There is one app I know that was
on track for FDA approval and
that was an app that was
created by Para Therapeutics
that was made to be used in
the context of substance abuse.
But that was one again,
that helps diagnose people and
then provided the information
to their provider.
So it really has to be
under the current sort of
FDA purview of what they've
said they're gonna regulate in
digital health space.
It needs to be used in
the context of treatment.
>> So mental health is similar
then to the fitness apps that
are out there [INAUDIBLE]?
>> Exactly, yep, yep.
>> Thanks.
>> Is there anyway of
recording appers events?
So does anybody track these?
>> No,
not in sort of the public space.
I think and that's one thing I
think is also really important
is where, this bipolar app I
mentioned that has this very
sort of Potentially dangerous
recommendation in there.
And I think, again, right now
it's a very sort of wild lust.
And that would be a good
thing to kind of get.
It's like collecting more
information about when these
apps do go seriously wrong.
>> And
I apologize if I'm mistaken.
I believe that APA also
has an app ratings system.
>> By APA do you mean
the American Psychological
Association or the American
Psychiatric Association?
>> Shoot, I don't know.
[LAUGH]
>> So
the American Psychiatric
Association does have an app
rating system.
It follows a lot of the same
kind of guidelines of what we
do in PsyberGuide.
It's meant more to be
a consumer framework.
So what the American Psychiatric
Association has done is it
sets up sort of a tiered system
of if you're a consumer and
you wanna look at
a mental health app,
these are the things
you should consider.
Privacy and security,
effectiveness, user experience,
interoperatibility.
I think that's really great but
I think as a consumer,
I would have, if you told me
about if I want to go buy a car.
And you told me these are the
things that you should consider
when you're buying a car.
Safety, gas mileage.
All these things, you can tell
me the value of those things but
I'm not gonna know how to do it.
And so I think that's a little
bit of where I think that
the American Psychiatric
Association framework does
a really nice job of saying
what we should look at.
But I think that consumers often
need that sort of extra step to
get there.
>> Definitely, did you use
it as kind of a guide?
>> A lot of the sort of areas
that we cover overlap with
the American Psychiatric
Association with the exception
of the privacy security section.
That's something we're
debating a lot internally.
So there was a group that tried
to evaluate health apps more
generally, known as Haptic.
And Haptic got in big trouble
because they had a model where
they would do individual sort
of certification of apps.
Kind of like you would want
the FDA to do perhaps.
And they got into hot water when
there are a couple apps that
they sort of signed off on.
It was shown that they were
actually selling users' data to
third parties.
And so I think that's one of the
problems that you run into with
this privacy and security
is that, it's hard to know
sometimes with these apps where
the data actually is going,
what people are doing with data.
And some organizations
are not so clear with that.
And so again,
it's hard to provide sort
of recommendation of, this
is a secure app if you don't
have of all of the information
from it yourself.
>> If I'm in the App Store and
I'm looking for
an anxiety app, how would I even
know that PsyberGuide existed?
>> That's a great question.
I think that that's one
thing that we are trying
to do is partner
with organizations.
We have an agreement with Mental
Health America to partner with
their screening exercise.
Where people get screened
through Mental Health America,
and then can get recommendations
for different services.
Right now there's no way of
knowing about it, and I think
without teaming with those app
stores themselves, that's gonna
be a problem that's not gonna
be able to be overcome.
So I wanna transition to a
little bit more research around
how and why people use
mental health apps.
This is a penny arcade comic
that I really like that makes me
think about this from years ago.
Where apps were really
just blowing up and
the two characters are fighting
about whether one should buy
a console game or app games.
And I love this quote here,
well you buy one 3DS
Nintendo game and
I'll buy 40 games on my phone
and we'll see who has more fun.
So sort of this idea of yeah,
you can support using $40 on one
game or I can spend $40
on 40 different games and
we'll see who actually gets
more enjoyment out of this.
Kind of arguing for
this model of diversity
in terms of products.
So one of the things
that we did recently
is we looked at users who were
interested in entering into
different clinical trials that
we were doing at the Center for
Behavioral and
Intervention Technologies.
And before they got onboarded
into any of our trials,
we actually just
simply asked them what
sort of health apps do
you have on your phone,
what sort of mental health apps
do you have on your phone?
Why do you use these apps?
What are the app names?
And we found that most
people use multiple apps.
The average was two,
there's a range from 0 to 20.
So again, this isn't suggesting
that people are finding one
health app and they're using it.
They're using this penny arcade
sort of model of trying a bunch
of different things and
seeing what's helpful for them.
About one-fourth of them
were mental health or
wellness apps, which corresponds
somewhat with the sort of
overall representation.
Again, probably this number is
a bit elevated from the general
population because these are all
people who are entering into
a clinical trial that was
focused on mental health.
92.8% were free.
And it's worth knowing that
this is not representative of
the overall sort of marketplace
of mental health apps, so People
are disproportionately focused
on downloading free apps for
their health, which I think
is really interesting.
And also, again, it's not
representative if you just look
at the marketplace review
of what's out there.
In our data, we found that if
we looked at the purposes for
the applications, the most
common reason people said
they were using mental
health applications was for
tracking purposes.
About 40% of the apps
that people were using,
they said they were using for
some sort of tracking purpose.
What was really interesting to
me actually was that when we
looked at the names of
the different apps that people
were using, there was
not a large proportion.
But there was a proportion of
apps that they had noted that
were not mental health apps.
They were not
health apps at all.
They were things like Snapchat,
like Google Documents,
like Facebook, like Twitter.
And people actually reported
using these different things for
health purposes.
And so I think that's another
interesting piece to this puzzle
here that as clinical
psychologists,
we often look at the app store.
We look at things.
People search for anxiety.
People search for depression.
And those are the things
we're evaluating.
But there's a lot of way
that people might be using
non-health apps for
health purposes.
And I think that we as a field
should better understand when
that's going on.
What people are getting
out of that.
And how we can actually maybe
build some of these tools to
better meet the mental health
needs that people are having
when they're going through
these different things.
So I wanna loop back
to that IMS report.
Because I think it actually has
some interesting points to make
about what the apps actually
do in terms of functionality.
So back in 2015 when the IMS
looked at all of the different
health apps that are available,
they noticed that about half the
apps had a single functionality.
So that means that most
of the apps do one thing.
And that most of the time,
that functionality
was to inform people.
So effectively, most health
apps that are out there
are psychoeducational tools
that teach people things.
They're self-help books that had
been made into an app format.
Self-help books are great.
We've had them for years.
They can be useful for people.
But I think what's going on
here is a sad opportunity,
a lost opportunity,
I should say,
to use the true affordances
of digital technologies to do
really creative things
in the health space.
There's, I think it was about 5%
here of apps that were used for
communication purposes.
So the ability to connect to
people, either to each other.
And that was actually what
was most common is that.
So of that small percentage of
apps that have communication
purposes, most of the time,
those apps are allowing people
to connect to social media.
Maybe that's the best thing for
health apps to do,
maybe it's not.
I'm not gonna open
up the debate here.
But I'm just saying
that's the most common
communication purpose is
let's share our health
information to social media.
34 were just social networks,
again, a social
component to that.
2% went to providers.
So very few health apps actually
have any sort of information of
interoperability that allows
information to be translated
from a user to a provider.
Again, I think this is
a big missed opportunity.
I was talking with Mary a little
bit about this earlier,
about how we actually can take
information from different
health apps and be able to
share that with providers.
And I think we need a lot more
understanding of what providers
want in those circumstances.
What patients want in
those circumstances.
And how to best translate
patient needs and
wants to provider needs and
wants.
So I wanna just, go ahead.
>> Just curiously,
that 2% provider communication,
is that related to just not
right building a functionality
into the app to begin with
cuz they don't want to?
Or is it because of EHR barrier,
integration barriers?
>> That's a good question.
I think it's probably
a little bit of both.
I mean, getting information to
the EHR is a huge headache.
I know at Northwestern,
we're just starting this
new initiative called, man,
it's like project one or
something like that.
Where they're trying to bring
all of the instances of epic to
have one version, where they'll
all communicate with each other.
And in the process of doing
that, they've completely locked
down introduction of new
information to the EHR.
So we can't put any information.
It's just whenever I do
projects, that is a non-starter.
No information gets
to go into the EHR.
I've seen some workarounds,
where information can be
translated into a document that
can be uploaded as a attachment
to a provider message.
But direct integration
of the EHR
has been a major headache for
any project I've worked on.
So imagine that's a big barrier
for a lot of other people, too.
>> [INAUDIBLE] So
I don't know if you've
asked this question or not.
Did you ask or find a new thing
in the literature about how
people find out about
the health apps that they use?
>> We didn't look in
that specific study.
We have a current study where
we're trying to ask that
question to find more like,
where do you come
to health apps?
And also what we're really
interested in the current state
we're doing is when they look
for them, what information
would be most valuable to them
to direct their decision?
I think it's a big
open question.
Yeah, I think it's
worth looking into.
>> On the 2% of [INAUDIBLE]
communicate to providers,
could providers actually do
anything with the information?
Or is it still like you said
that's where you have to look at
both sides?
>> That's a tricky question.
Can I come back to that
at the end of the talk?
Cuz I think there might be
a little bit more discussion to
have around that.
But that's a really good and
tricky question.
So I wanna actually go into
another platform that we've
developed at Northwestern
that we call IntelliCare.
And it takes a slightly
different design perspective to
mobile mental health.
So what IntelliCare is is
instead of a single app,
we've developed
an app suite that's
organized by this
hub application.
So the IntelliCare app suite
actually has 12 different
mini applications that
each focus on a specific
behavior change technique.
So here's a couple of them.
This is actually one of
our most popular apps.
It's called Daily Feats.
When you sign up for the app,
you take a brief depression and
anxiety screener.
I'll say IntelliCare was
intentionally designed to deal
with issues of depression and
anxiety.
So you take a depression and
anxiety screener.
It gives you a set of
tasks to do each day.
Daily feats that are organized
around your level of
depression and anxiety.
So if you are pretty
depressed when you start out,
you'll have just
very basic feats.
Get out bed, groom yourself,
make good food choices,
go outside.
I will say these might
seem very basic to you.
But the feedback we've gotten
from our users is that it's
extremely empowering for them
when they're seriously depressed
for us to reframe these things
that they truly struggle with as
feats to be accomplished.
So you open up the application.
You check off which
things you do that day.
If you form a streak
over multiple days,
you get a little indication
in terms of green numbers.
You have enough streaks
over subsequent days,
you move up to
subsequent levels.
And you continue to keep
leveling up, get more and
more challenging things.
Very simple application,
very easy to use, very,
very popular in our suite.
>> Define a streak.
>> Five days of
completing a goal.
This is an app that I developed.
It's called MyMantra.
I call it the Pinterest of
cognitive behavioral therapy.
You collect pictures that
organize around a positive
self-affirming mantra.
There's a couple example ones
in here in the application.
Things like I'm strong,
I'm grateful, I'm resilient.
And as you collect these photos,
you get them fed back to
you through notifications.
Again, very, very simple,
a popular app within our suite.
This is Thought Challenger.
It's maybe the most classic
mental health app that's in
the IntelliCare suite.
It helps walk you through
the process of cognitive
restructuring.
Which is this idea that the
content of your thoughts is more
important than
the actual situation.
It helps you come up with
more positive ways to view
situations.
So you come up with a negative,
unrealistic thought.
You substitute it with a more
realistic way of thinking.
This walks you through the
five-step process of doing that.
And on the home screen,
you have all of the good,
positive reframe thoughts,
a word cloud that's
generated from that content.
We wanna throw the positive
content back at
people as opposed to
the negative content.
So we did a 8-week field trial
of the IntelliCare platform.
I will say that it was done
along with coached support.
We had a person providing some
light encouragement engagement
through text messaging.
This is the result from that
single arm field trial.
We found that people over 8
weeks experienced significant
reductions in their levels of
depression as well as anxiety.
We just recently wrapped
up a 300-person,
4-armed randomized controlled
trial of intelliCare.
So we'll have more
data on this soon.
This again shows similar thing
but looks at the percent of
people who are in full
remission or recovery.
Which is indicated by clinically
set cut points in terms of
reductions on their same skills.
So people reduced in their
depression and anxiety.
This was actually one of the
more exciting findings to me,
which is that the use of
IntelliCare was pretty
consistent over
that 8-week period.
So we had an average launch
of about 25 sessions per
week in an average time of
one minute per session.
So people really were going to
these apps multiple times per
day, using them in
very short bursts.
And that that use was sustained
over this eight week period.
In most mental health apps, you
see a pattern where people might
use it for a week or two, and
then it drops off dramatically.
They call this the law
of attrition in digital
health research.
That it's pretty inevitable that
people will stop using these
things over time.
So at least this was sort of
good evidence that in this,
again, it's a coached trial.
So there is a human
supporter there,
this isn't people who're just
using things on their own.
We've done some evaluations
about uncoached, and
it's not as good as this.
But it still looks fairly good
in the Intellicare on the suite.
So this is just another thing
about treatment engagement.
The thing I think I wanna point
out here is that the average
time that the coaches used was
39 minutes over those eight
weeks.
So again, this is a very sort of
lean protocol that these coaches
are doing.
This is not full sort of
therapy that's done through
text messaging.
It's about three text messages
per week that are sent to
the user to sort of
encourage them to continue
to use the platform, yeah.
>> Are you gonna enter
those notifications or
emails every day?
>> So there's some
notifications through the apps.
It's organized by,
we have a hub app that
actually provides messaging.
And so all those notifications
hit the central hub, so
they're all kind of
contained within the app.
Another thing actually,
within that hub app,
is one thing thatt we're really
interested in, is if we can use
this IntelliCare platform
as a recommendation engine.
And so, one of the arms in that,
so I'll say that four arm field
trial is a two by two design.
So we compared coaching
versus no coaching.
And we compared a full
IntelliCare hub app that had
notifications and
recommendations.
So every week, you would get
a new recommendation that says
this week, try out these two
IntelliCare apps for you.
Versus an IntelliCare app, a hub
app that just had the sort of
available IntelliCare
apps within that hub.
So no notifications and
no recommendations.
So one of the things that
we're really interested in is,
can we actually take these apps?
And then figure out which
app should the person use in
the next week?
So this is just a little
representation of what that
IntelliCare hub looks like.
This is the non-recommending
version of the hub app.
So in the recommending version,
you'll have a little box
here that would say,
these are the two apps
you should use this week.
So right now, it looks like
initial data suggesting that
we're actually able to increase
use of the applications through
these recommendations.
And that the recommendation
engine that we're using is
actually improving on
a naive recommender,
that's just giving
random recommendations.
So it does seem like we are able
to do a little bit of this
recommendation.
But I think this is something
where we have a lot of kind of
room to improve in our platform.
>> One other question.
>> Yeah.
>> When you are recommending
[INAUDIBLE].
I mean obviously,
you're recommending and
prescribing them to use this.
And that other arm where you
just gave them coached or
non-coached, do
they get to choose?
Was there any choice with
using a computer, or?
>> Yep, yes, exactly.
Well, even in the recommended
one they can use other apps too.
So it's not that those are the
only ones available to them.
We're just pushing them
towards particular ones.
And these apps are all
freely available on
the Google Play Store.
A couple of them are in the iOS,
we've either got,
think we've got three to five
that are in iOS already.
I know the development is
kind of rolling out for
all of the iOS ones.
We do find that people
from the public store,
who download the hub tend to
download more applications than
people who don't
download the hub too.
So this hub points people to
things that they wouldn't be
finding otherwise.
Just looking at IntelliCare
apps, generally,
from the Play Store.
>> Has anybody had support
from a healthcare provider in
recommending or
kind of influencing [CROSSTALK]
>> So
we have not tested it within
a healthcare system yet.
That's a project we have on the
horizon is actually doing this
in healthcare settings.
Where your providers, or
a member of your provider
team would be that supporter.
So far, supporters,
we start out with clinical
psychologists from our group.
We moved to research assistants,
because as I said,
we're not doing very fancy stuff
with the recommendations here.
I mean, one thing we're also
really interested in is if we
could automate some of those
recommendations through using
natural language processing.
Because at least our reports
from the people doing
the support is that,
what they're doing is not stuff
that's all that challenging.
But yeah, I think these are a
lot of open questions we have
with how we might be able
to use this platform.
So I wanna move on to another
sort of pilot study that we've
been working on in Chicago aimed
at providing mental health
resources to homeless youth,
so Every year about 2 million
folks ages kind of 18 through
24 will spend a night homeless.
And the rates of mental
health disorders and
homeless individuals
are about two to three
times higher than
the general population.
At the same time, only about 10%
of those folks get any sort of
access to mental
health resources.
So we have a highly vulnerable
population, huge sort of need
for mental health services, very
little sort of availability.
So what we've done in Chicago is
we've launched a project that we
call Stepping Stone.
Stepping Stone has a couple
of different components.
First, every youth who
signs up for our study,
we give them a smartphone device
that's theirs to keep and
we pay for six months
of their data service.
It's one thing that we
feel very strongly is that
keeping them connected to having
technology as a resource is
very beneficial for them.
This has been
an interesting challenge.
We've learned a lot of sort
of interesting things.
So we give them a data
plan of five gigabytes.
They get throttled if
they go above that.
We had one period where our
provider was switching over
carriers, and
that throttling was turned off.
We had a youth that used 120
gigabytes of data in one week.
It was crazy.
I mean, they're never on Wi-Fi.
They're using this as
their entertainment,
as their communication,
as everything.
It's been a very interesting
learning experience.
In addition, we put three
applications on their phone.
We used two of those
IntelliCare apps.
One focused on meditation and
mindfulness called Purple Chill.
Another one focused on sleep
hygiene called Slumber Time.
We have a daily survey
app on their phone called
Pocket Helper.
It sends a survey that asks
them about what their biggest
challenge was that day,
what's their stress level like,
what was their
sleep quality like.
And it feeds that information
back to a therapist in our team.
That therapist, they set up
three 30 minute phone calls that
focus around kinda
general coping skills.
They also have the opportunity
to text message that therapist
at times outside of
those phone calls.
That's one reason why we're
collecting this daily survey
information so that if they
text or call the therapist
kinda outside of the scheduled
sessions, that the therapist
knows a little bit more about
what's going on in their life.
And that's what
the project consists of.
This is what sort of that
daily survey looks like.
It gives them a coping kind of
tip every day that they rate on
a five point scale.
I think, it feeds back their
survey data to them and
we ask them kinda
those brief questions.
So this is sort of
the general model.
We have a back end dashboard
that provides that information
to the clinician.
The clinician gets that
information and they are able to
intervene if something comes up,
to send kind of text message
support in the moment or as
close to the moment as possible.
And then the youth are able to
text back to our therapist.
So we've run this
project now with about,
I think we have now about 40
people who've been recruited.
Most people really
like the study.
They like the tips the best.
They like the apps the least.
This is something that's been
really interesting to us,
because the tips are really
easy for us to develop.
The apps are very expensive and
hard.
And so, it makes me
wonder sometimes like,
why are we building apps?
Why don't we just
send tips to people?
It's a good question.
Most people would recommend
the study for other people.
We haven't looked at
the clinical outcomes yet, but
we've had sort of encouraging
results from the engagement.
Actually, initially,
our engagement looked
really bi-modal.
People would either
engage in everything.
They would complete
all their sessions.
They would text
message regularly or
they would kind of
disappear completely.
We've actually
recently sort of had
one more sort of
bucket of engagement.
So we have the people
who don't engage at all.
We have the people who complete
all their phone sessions and
text message regularly.
And now we have a group of folks
who aren't completing any of
the phone sessions,
but they're texting regularly
with the therapist.
So it seems like there's
different ways to engage people
in these platforms, and
I think that that's
an important thing to remember,
is like what is
the expected use.
And also what are patterns
of engagement that might be
interesting and useful for
the person doing it.
But I think a lot of time when
we look at digital mental
health, people think
about adherence.
They use that word a lot and I'm
a little skittish with the word
adherence, because adherence
kind of suggests to me
that there's one
way of interacting.
It's like we have a medication,
you're supposed to use it
three times a day, I'm like,
I don't know if digital mental
health is the same sort of way.
So I really like to think about
this as sort of engagement or
usage.
But there's different ways
that people might engage with
the platform.
But then it doesn't mean
that one way is necessarily
the best way or
we should preference one style
of engagement besides the other.
I think we need to learn
more about what styles of
engagement are useful for
different folks.
>> Why did they like
the apps the least?
>> I think one of the reasons
is that they weren't
well-integrated into
the program that we had.
I also think that the sleep
app we put on there,
because that was one of our sort
of first goals for this project,
was to work with sleep hygiene.
And the kids are actually
not all that
interested in sleep hygiene.
There's a lot of other things
that they have going on.
I think, there are problems
with depression anxiety,
also slightly different
than in general population.
So, there's a lot of sort
of emotional regulation in
interpersonal issues
that come up.
Those are the main content
that kinda came up
in the text messages
in the fund sessions.
And we don't have apps
that kind of specifically,
address those things.
And so, even though the sort
of treatment, like cognitive
behavioral therapy would still
be a treatment strategy that
would be useful.
We might need to
develop apps that kind
of focus on the specific
content areas that would be
interesting to those group.
So I think, tailoring for
particular population is sort
of really key and critical.
>> One last thing on that.
I was just curious about
what apps you decided,
how you go about deciding what
apps you are going to put on?
>> So one, was because
our funder was funding to
do sort of sleep stuff, and so
we put the sleep app on there.
We're always tied a little
bit by where our money is
coming from.
And then, the Mindfulness app,
we put on there because it
reinforced a lot of the coping
skills that we were teaching
in those fund sessions.
That is actually something
we are moving to a phase two
project here.
And in the phase two,
we are putting more diversity of
apps on there, because we have
the apps available to us
in the healthcare suite.
It might make sense just to
give them all to them, and
see which ones they use.
So, here's actually, I wanna
conclude real fast with a kind
of conceptual thing that I
talk a lot about in my work.
That I think I wanna frame
a little bit differently here,
because being here at Microsoft,
I know that this might be a term
that some people
are familiar with.
And I use it slightly different
than it's used in
common literature.
So the term skeuomorphism is a
term that's used a lot in UI/UX
design.
To talk about visual elements
that exist in digital
technologies that are remnants
of the past physical
examples of that.
So, I used this example here of
light bulbs that looked like
candle flames,
because that's what candles
looked like in the past.
Those things could be anything,
they could be dinosaurs,
they could be hockey pucks,
but we decided to make them
candle to look like fire.
This is a great example I
got from a presentation,
where someone says,
I showed my 12 year old
son an old floppy disk.
And he said, wow, cool,
you 3D printed the save icon.
No, that's the opposite way that
works, we made a save icon that
represented the way that
we used to save things.
So, I think that often in
digital mental health,
we actually engage in
conceptual skeumorphisms.
Where we take concepts from
face to face therapy, and
we translate them to
digital technologies.
So we make web-based cognitive
behavior therapy programs,
where we expect people to
come back on a weekly basis.
And spend 50 minutes
going through content,
because that's what
psychotherapy is like.
When, that's not the way
that most people use digital
technology.
And that maybe is
not the way that will be
most helpful to them.
And so, effectively, we
are trying to fit our old model
of psychological practice
into these digital mediums.
And I think, instead what
we should be doing is
we think about digital mental
health is re-imagining how
we can actually take unique
affordances of technologies.
To build new products, new
designs that actually leverage
what we know about
behavior change and
mental health strategies.
But do so in sort of the new
medium in technology.
So, here's actually a project
that I did with Alana Yorosh
from the University
of Minnesota.
Where we were sort of very
interesting the stakeholder
engage perspective around
happiness technologies.
So we did a six week, sorry,
yeah, six week cooperative
inquiry, sort of co-design
workshop with kids around
happiness technologies.
So this was a true sort of
interdisciplinary project,
I came in as the clinical
psychologist with a background
in positive psychology.
We spent the first couple of
weeks of the workshop teaching
kids about
the inventing process.
And also, teaching them
process psychology skills, so
I did what, I will typically
do as a psychologist if I was
running just
a psychology workshop.
And then we transitioned to,
okay, now that we've empowered
you with the concept and
the knowledge of.
We talked to you
about gratitude,
we talked to you about
mindfulness, we talked to you
about some problem solving
from a cognitive perspective.
What sort of technologies would
you guys build that would be
able to promote well being?
And if it came up with some
really sort of interesting
examples.
This is my favorite one here,
this is the mindfulness
backpack.
It had a little sort of
distraction machine on the back,
to be able to take people out
of whatever moment they're in.
It also had a good
smell generator.
And the kinda good smells these
kids came up with were chocolate
chip cookies, and
the smell of their own bed.
Just really sort of
cool creative things.
They also came up with things
that were very similar to
some things that
have been designed.
So this was their sort of
thought tank that used fish,
which I think is kind of funny,
because I've seen a lot of sort
of designs from different folks
where they use animals or
fish as kind of representations
of mental sort of health
processes and sort of visual
displays for applications.
But this one is kind of coming
up with a positive cognitive
reframe.
So the fish here are saying,
I'm smart.
Kind of counteracting some
negative thoughts that they had.
But it was really sort of
interesting, engaging, and
useful to engage in this
process with the kids.
Another thing I thought that was
really interesting was looking
at the engagement strategies
they came up with,
with how would you want to
entice kids to stay engaged with
these different technologies?
We definitely saw the sort of
typical engagement strategies
that come up in what
a lot of people design.
Games, gamification.
Heath is huge.
Although I have a separate rant,
I'll tell you another time about
my theories on gamification.
Social support is big, but
actually some of the things I
thought were really interesting
were responding directly
to emotions or thoughts.
Making these things more
tangible for people.
It was also really interesting,
if we go back to this example
here, you can see that most of
the things that the kids came
up with were some form
of embodied technology.
Wearables, backpacks,
robots, watches.
They really wanted something
they could touch and feel.
If you look at the digital
mental health space,
most of the stuff is software.
We have very few wearable,
tangible technologies that
are trying to promote mental
health, especially in kids.
I think this is a space that
really would be interesting
to develop.
So I think that teaming with
kids gave us some interesting
ideas about what are different
things that people would
be interested in.
I think more of this sort
of co-design process needs
to be done in digital
mental health.
Again, I'm probably preaching
to the choir a little bit here.
But I think coming from a
clinical psychology background,
this is typically not what
clinicians do when they develop
new mental health technologies.
>> A device that slaps you if
you're not being grateful.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah,
there was also sort of this.
I actually thought this was
a theme that was really sort
of interesting with kids is that
there was this interesting sort
of balance between
the positive and the negative.
And that they wanted things that
sort of identified the negative
experiences that they
were going through, and
had some ways to try to
incorporate the positive aspect.
And so, that's a really sort
of interesting dichotomy that
doesn't show up in sort of more
broad sort of discussion of
positive psychology.
So again, some of these ideas
are sort of off the wall.
I will say that at least
in the iteration process,
I think that something that was
sort of unique about the way
that we did this is we did this
sort of long-term workshop,
there were 14 sessions that
we did with the same kids.
They came back.
They learned more about
the inventing process.
The amount of ideas they
generated sort of decreased over
time and the quality
of their ideas tended
to get better
throughout session.
So definitely, they learned
along the way how to engage in
this process with us.
And I think most of the times,
again,
I come from a clinical
psychology background.
I'm not a designer even
though I love this stuff.
But most of the people I see
doing sort of this type of work
in psychology tend to do
a workshop with a group of kids
and move on to another workshop
with another group of kids.
And I think there is this
sort of interesting aspect
of trying to think better on how
to team over the long-term with
the stakeholders that we're
working with, cuz I think that's
a big part of this sort
of mental health journey.
Is that we design a lot of these
sort of singular experiences, or
experiences that are meant
to stay stable over time.
And that's not the way
therapy works,
that's not the way life works,
that's not the way
mental health works.
And I think we need to better
think about also how we allow
tools to be flexible
to allow for
a variety of different
interactions.
So just a couple of
conclusions here.
There's lots of mobile
mental health options that
are out there.
They're actually being
developed at a breakneck pace.
Every single day, it seems
like there is some new app or
new product or
new something that someone's
doing in digital mental health.
The diversity of mobile mental
health options is somewhat
limited, though.
A lot of people tend to
be building the same sort
of things.
I have seen so
many cognitive behavioral
therapy thought record apps.
We built a cognitive behavioral
therapy sort of thought
record app.
And the quality is unknown.
And so I think that one of our
goals right now should be to
introduce some more variance,
some more diversity into
the products, the designs,
the things we're evaluating.
And use the information we
have available to us to better
understand which of
these things work and
which of these things don't.
And then again, to kinda go back
to this theme I mentioned at
the beginning about this
excitement, this enthusiasm for
digital mental health has not
been matched by implementation.
We see lots of things that
are out there that have been
developed.
We've not seen a lot of things
that have really caught on.
At least in the area of
kind of depression anxiety,
there's been somewhere on
the magnitude of 100 randomized
controlled trials
evaluating these things.
There's not been one sort of
successful implementation where
these things have caught on and
stayed around in
a healthcare system.
And I think that one of the big
problems for that is these
things have not been designed
with implementation in mind.
And we haven't really deeply
thought about how these things
can integrate into
the healthcare systems that
they're in.
These are just some examples
of sort of recent designs, or
different things in mobile
mental health that have been
rolled out there.
And I think one thing that's
been really interesting to me,
as an observer in this field, is
that we see more and more sort
of work where we're seeing these
things pop up in places where we
don't think about these things
as a mental health tool.
So Facebook's efforts to try to
do suicide identification or
outreach, the Google calendar
feature a sort of recommended
goal and times where we have
open spaces in our calendar.
This is behavior activation.
This is something we've been
doing in clinical psychology for
years and years and years.
You get people more active, and
you get people more engaged and
naturally reinforcing things,
spending time with other people,
being physically active, this
will help your mental health.
And so I think there's
a lot of places where
clinical psychology ideas
could be well implemented and
integrated into existing
technologies if it's done
thoughtfully and
if it's done usefully.
This kind of goes back to the
theme I sort of mentioned with
the paper we did,
reviewing different health apps
that people were using where
people identified health
uses from non-health apps.
So in conclusion,
I just wanna acknowledge many of
the people who helped me do this
work as well as some of my
different funding organizations
that have helped
to support this.
And I think we have a little
bit of time for questions, but
I do wanna kinda come back
to the question of sort of
a integration into
healthcare settings.
But thank you all for
your attention.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Sure, yeah.
So I think it's
a really tricky thing.
There's a project that I've been
working on right now where we
developed a platform that's
made to be used in the context
of cognitive behavioral
therapy for depression,
and we did that through
sort of a usage and
design with both patients and
providers.
And those groups have
very different goals and
very different
sort of interests.
And so I think,
we need better ways to
bring the information that
patients or people create into
the clinical setting in ways
that are usable to clinicians.
And so there's a project also,
another project I'm working on
where we're trying to use Fitbit
data in an intensive outpatient
program for veterans with PTSD
to try to get information
about activity levels,
sleep levels that might be
able to inform the treatment.
But I think what we
really need to know is,
what are sort of the treatment
goals that providers have and
how can this information,
this data, be most useful for
the things that
they're accomplishing.
So I think it's
a design problem, but
I think it's one
that's surmountable.
>> Sounds like a similar shape,
I thought maybe you'd be
a little more advanced,
like some cardiovascular health
area because we've been talking
to providers there, too.
And a lot of information that
they get at cardiovascular
health is not usable
to the provider.
But the patients find
it very interesting.
Whether it's valid or not,
they still find it interesting.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Yes, I think,
one thing that we found in some
sayings, is that it might be
the case that we're gonna have
to create new professions
of people who are going to be
able to deal with that data.
Cuz again, like
the cardiovascular folks and
providers usually don't
have a lot of time, but
if you could have another role
sort of develop that could be,
sort of the information
collector and presenter,
I think that might be something.
>> There would be some
way to provide them that.
So a physician we were talking
to said the same thing.
If there were some way to
take that information and
boil it down to something
useful to a treatment
plan that a physician
could recommend,
then maybe they'd have
some use for the data.
>> Otherwise,
it becomes just noise to them.
>> Yep, exactly, yep.
>> Grades.
>> Sorry?
>> Well done physicians and
pharmacists and.
>> Yeah, I've heard that.
>> Yeah, I don't like that but
it's an interesting
model about how it goes.
>> What was it?
>> I don't know.
>> So
why don't you like gamification?
There's such a huge
push [INAUDIBLE].
>> So I think gamification,
we did have points in this.
So I think gamification has
to be done very mindfully for
two aspects.
One that, if we're dealing
with mental health,
I think we wanna make sure
that we respect that for
many people this is a very
serious, very challenging thing.
And I don't think we don't want
to necessarily transform this
into a game for them.
I think the other sort of
aspect, I borrow a phrase from
Ian Bogus that he talks about
chocolate covered broccoli,
is that So
we know chocolate's good,
we know broccoli's good for us.
Most of us are willing
to tolerate broccoli
because we know it's good for
us even if we don't love it.
We love chocolate, but
you don't want to put
those two things together.
And so I think gamification
is that sometimes.
It's like,
we know health is good for us,
we know these things are good.
We know games are fun and
we like to do them.
But you don't wanna just
spread the games all over
the health stuff.
So I think that if you, one,
sort of belittle a person's
emotional experience in
the context of mental disorders.
And two, make it more about
the extrinsic engagement in
the gaming component, as opposed
to the intrinsic value that they
get out of the activity,
I think that's very challenging.
At the same time, we know game
mechanics, we know challenges.
That's a big part of
sort of mental health.
Something I say all the time
is that one of the secrets to
really getting people hooked
into the things that we do or
getting people moving in
the right direction is
clear goals and
immediate feedback.
And that's a game.
So I think that we can
integrate gaming elements, but
the term gamification
scares me sometimes.
So that's my gamification rant,
chocolate covered brocoli.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah?
>> I have a two-part
question about PsyberGuide.
How do you choose which
apps you wanna evaluate?
Second is, you mentioned that
the scores are different for
your PsyberGuide ratings and
the App Store ratings.
I was wondering what is
the correlation between
those ratings?
>> So I think the correlation
there is about 0.15.
I would have to
look it up again.
It's pretty low.
So I answered that first cuz
it's the easier
question to answer.
In terms of prioritizing apps,
we have sort of a multi-stage
prioritization process.
We do a consistent review of
the scientific literature,
again, because one
of the sort of
the aspects we're rating
things on is credibility.
We know that things are gonna
get higher credibility scores if
they're in the scientific
literature and
so we try to sort
of promote those.
We then do sort of
a prioritization based on
a popularity score
that's a combination of
the number of downloads and the
reviews from the public stores.
As well as sort of
identification through
searches and other
appearances in media sources.
So if people
are talking about it,
we wanna make sure
that it's represented.
If there's an app that's
up there that's not
really being used,
people aren't talking about it,
it's not as important for
us to rate.
Especially if we don't have good
evidence that has scientific
support or sort of clinical
content behind it.
So those are sort of the main
factors we use to sort of
identify and to propose them.
We also get some sort of
self-referrals through
a developer, his design and
application.
They want it redone
in Psyberguide.
And so I think we get, depending
on the week, five to ten people
contacting us about,
would you post my thing or
would you evaluate this thing
that I've seen out there?
I think a lot of times we get
things of people who have
created some sort of
self-help site that
has just content on it, which is
not the sort of stuff we review.
And we also get a lot
of requests from B2B or
to business products.
So platforms are trying to sell
to healthcare settings or to
businesses to provide some sort
of mental health support for
their employees or
the folks that they cover.
We currently are not evaluating
those because we're meant
to be a more
consumer-facing website.
And then the other reason is
that a lot of businesses and
healthcare systems have the
resources to evaluate things,
and usually have their own
sort of evaluation criteria.
And so we're really trying
to provide a service for
people who don't have the
resources to evaluate things.
Or again, to kind of go back to
the American Psychiatric
Association framework,
maybe don't know how to
evaluate it themselves,
even if they're given
a little bit of a framework.
So we're trying to create
more information for
the people who need it.
>> I think we have time for
one more question.
We actually have a talk
starting at three, so
we have to be out of the room
by a quarter to, so.
[LAUGH] One more and then we'll-
>> Great.
>> I do if no one else does.
So you mentioned that
Thought Challenger.
You had very good results
with engagement and
usage over your
eight week trial.
And you said you didn't
think that the coaching was-
>> All of it, yeah.
>> Was responsible for it.
>> Well, sorry.
I don't think the coaching was
all of the engagement,
yeah, sure.
>> Yeah, so what was it about,
what future do you think-
>> I think one of the reasons is
that they were really designed
for very simple interactions.
They were meant to be brief.
That a lot of these other
applications we see tend to be
multi-featured.
So you'd have the thought
challenging piece in there with
an activity scheduling piece,
and a logging piece, and
some psycho-educational piece.
And so you have to really
dig into these applications
to get the thing that's useful.
And so I think that sort
of simple design of these
applications is actually sort
of useful to kind of increase
engagement.
And I think that was also shown
through at least the way that
people engage in these things
in kind of quick small bursts.
So I think that was
one piece of it.
I also think that because it's
an app suite as opposed to
a single application, I think
one of the problems I think
that mobile mental health
faces is that people,
when they go looking for
something, they're usually more
highly motivated than they
are gonna be at other things.
They might find an application,
they might start using it.
It might not work, and
they might then decide
to stop doing it.
And they might have a thought
like, I tried that digital
mental health stuff and
it doesn't work.
And I think by reframing
this as an app sweep,
there's is a little bit of
a reframe that can happen.
That we know not everything
works for everyone and
that's why we've made out
these different options.
And so if the first thing you
use doesn't work for you,
maybe something within
the suite will.
So what we find in a lot of
other areas of psychology when
we had these sort of multi-modal
sort of stuff is that these
kitchen sink approaches work
much better than approaches that
have sort of a single
piece to it.
I mean, so I think by sort of
unpacking the kitchen sink and
laying out the tools
kind of all separately,
it kind of helps people
engage with that platform.
That's just sort
of my conjecture.
We don't have a lot of
evidence speaking to that.
But I think that that's a thesis
kind of digging into it.
But we need to do more
research to figure that out.
It's a good question, cool.
>> All right,
let's thank [CROSSTALK].
>> Thanks, everybody.
>> [APPLAUSE].